bonjour alors je suis je suis daniel
daniel de belie re ah oui alors
attendons alors je alors je suis le
maître des lieux
enfin il ya d'autres gens qui habitent
là mais sur le papier c'est c'est beau
château quoi ça moi alors voilà donc ça
c'est la scène du conseil un accusé un
petit peu le bazar
on a fait un méchoui des prisonniers à
notre emblème wells et la grenouille
notre devise et des nénuphars à l'autre
mais on essaye d'en lancer une un petit
peu plus accrocheuse les mystères sont
de mise
parce qu'on aimerait développer un côté
un petit peu plus mystérieux forts de
notre grande expérience nous pensons que
nous sommes les dignes héritiers du
trône de fer un petit peu comme tout le
monde nous sommes les frogs pour assurer
le fonctionnement de cette maison je
suis entouré de gens formidablement
compétents et non rémunérés comme m
hurel à trimestre avec qui les mystères
sont de mise voici clarisse qui
maintient la maison en ordre et qui fait
la petite popote c'est sexiste puisque
c'est sexiste des fois être dit des mots
mais je comprends pas être une femme
lettrée entouré de sauvages sans
éducation c'est pas le plus dur non le
vrai problème c'est plus les tentatives
de viol pendant les repas nous sommes
les unique fabricant d'un bon nombre de
médecine que tout le royaume nous
envient la plus célèbre en temps de
guerre et en relais tao et voilà encore
un qui est content ou ça des
cailloux gens
si le trône de fer moi j'ai envie de
vous dire pourquoi pas on est une des
maisons les plus anciennes du royaume
notre maître d'armes c'est un descendant
des chercheurs de dragon du continent
disparu son ancêtre direct a vu les
derniers dragon vivant enfin c'est ce
qui nous a dit j'aimerais bien qu'on
arrête avec c'est ce qui nous a dit je
suis un fils de dragon juste j'ai pas de
papiers officiels les frogs peuvent
aisément gérer le royaume des neuf quoi
j'en accepte
l'accès mais est-ce que vous en maître
sur je suis sûr je me suis gouré accepte
mais on peut clairement et gérer encore
plus parce que j'ai dit que j'en avais 9
et qu'on pouvait les gérer en fait il
reste est assez facile on a un petit peu
l'épicerie mystérieuse ou la pharmacie
du royaume mais plus dans le sens vente
de drogue et posons est on bosse pour
tout le monde les gens pour qui je
travaille souhaite tuer le roi barbe à
papa les mystères sans le mit c'est quoi
ce bordel c'est la nouvelle devise en
fait oui non mais je m'en fous paraît
que vous avez du poison indétectable
exact nous avons du poison indétectable
seulement ce que vous en ferez emile ce
thème et j'en fais ce que je veux qu'on
le toit j'ai pas que ça à pour
qu'une devise se répandent ça l'a répété
beaucoup quelle masse corporelle à la
personne la personne qu'on veut donc on
peut donner et avec tous les mystères ce
monde il dit encore une fois et je t'ai
gorge et 7 points alors il est gros et
de la couperose rigole très fort pour
rien du tout alcoolique il est très gros
il a une barbe grisonnante et il est
souvent assis sur un trône de fer soit
il parlait de l'actuelle région du
royaume soit du pain donne
le roi est mort bon bah c'était pas le
père noël c'est la guerre les affaires
reprennent
[Musique]
non mais c'est une sale nouvelle colle